Bluetooth
ki ambulance us music has
proven falls over
spunkwire ki swadesh made target of pm10
using more bhai
this
[music]
thing hai insaniyat ko a [
music]
aur [
mera naam ko remove haq free munch bike dal
till last days
[  Sangeet] If it
happened to my mother, then due to illness, take her to the
hospital, otherwise mother, night and day. Mother,
Manvendra felt that
if someone takes me to the hospital, he does not know how to treat any person from
our village, Vinay, any mother,
with separate treatment.  If I don't
agree then he can reduce me to a motorcycle ambulance in my mind, that's
why I have taken two back
which is my bike [
music] It has
happened
that don't take a pack where do I go,
do medical, healthy kilometer C kilometer bank
but give free service  I
got my number, that wart is
very good for us at home, he is this one at
2 o'clock in the night, this margin chicken comes
to me every now and then
[music] I am
afraid of all these, I
wear
my bike when going to the jungle temple, Aniket, the elephant comes out  I am
late for many express trains, how far away am
I, how much bill do I have to pay, so
I have to
look at our people after tomorrow, and there is family, there is success
and there is a film, I am not alone in this, now I am
very stressed in one task.  At this
time, my boy, people click
less than me, this message
also runs 'write do subscribe' but there is no problem,
my wife Jagat was my voice, my grandfather, I
do very little, I boy people, a fan of scholarship,
threatened the consumer.  And due to some
religious background, I did
some work for that in the village and I tell in one place that the
work should be done
that my father is very big that everything is
hot for me, my brother is standing in front of me,
my life was saved.  I
too am very happy, it feels good in my heart to do such a thing, please
do it
for Ajay
[Music]